♪ ♪ ♪
- Zubin Mehta est une légende
bien vivante de la musique
classique. De passage à la
souvient
que pour a commencé
à l'Orchestre symphonique
de Montréal.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Né à Bombay, en Inde, d'un
père vest devenu le directeur ml
de l'OSM en 1961. Il avait
à peine 24 ans. En 1963,
il a participé à l'inauguration
Wilfrid-Pelletier de la
Place-des-arts et il a dirigé
premières tournées européennes
de son histoire.
♪ ♪ ♪
- La carvolée après son départ
de Montréal en 1967. Il a dirigé
entre autres l'orchestre
philarmonique de Los Angeles
de New York jusqu'en 1991.
Et pendant cinquante ans,
il a donné 4000 concertsueueueue
d'Israël dont un premier concert
en Allemagne en 1971.
♪ ♪ ♪
- De passage à Montréal pour
l'enregi
avec l'OSM, à 85 ans, Zubin
Mehta est encore lser
à la retraite.
entretien, le maestro n'a pu
s'empêcher de no
qu'il est encore tout jeune
et qu'il n'a aucune limite.
♪ ♪ ♪
Ici Louis-Philippe Ouimet,
Radio-Canada, Mon